[Música]
Cristina Fernández de kirchner es tal
vez una de las más relevantes figuras de
la historia reciente de la política
Argentina la dos veces el presidente de
ese país suramericano y actual
vicepresidenta tiene serios líos con la
justicia de su país Fernando Fernández
es acusada de fraude agravado también de
liderar asociación ilícita que tal
parece estuvo relacionado con un esquema
de sobornos que a su vez estuvo
relacionado con proyectos de
infraestructura en el sur del país en la
región de la Patagonia
de acuerdo con las indagaciones la
vicepresidenta desvió ciento de millones
de dólares en contratos financiados por
los contribuyentes argentinos a un socio
de negocios y también a un amigo de su
familia todo esto para construir
diferentes carreteras como lo decía en
la región de la Patagonia en el extremo
sur del país estos proyectos No fueron
concluidos o en el peor de los casos se
pasaron drásticamente de sus
presupuestos para poder ser concretados
tres jueces han determinado El veredicto
Fernández de kirchner Fue sentenciada
entonces a seis años de prisión aunque
los fiscales federales estaban pidiendo
12 años de detención la ex presidenta
también recibió inhabilitación perpetua
Para ocupar cargos públicos
Aunque tiene derecho a apelar El
veredicto mientras esto tiene algún
trámite en la justicia Argentina esto
podría
permitirle postularse a otros cargos
públicos mientras esta apelación pues
tiene lugar en los juzgados argentinos
esto recordemos que las próximas
elecciones en Argentina están previstas
para el año 2023 aunque ya Fernández de
kirchner dijo a través de sus redes
sociales y dijo a todo su electorado que
no se presentará a estos comicios
presidenciales por ahora ya lo veremos
en unos meses esta decisión judicial no
conlleva un arresto inmediato por eso
ella sigue en libertad porque en su
defensa la vicepresidenta puede apelar
esta sentencia en diferentes instancias
de la justicia Argentina hasta llegar
incluso a la Corte Suprema que de hecho
esta instancia es la que tiene la última
palabra en todo este proceso que podría
prolongarse por varios meses o varios
años el tribunal también sentenció a
otros 12 acusados entre ellos también
está el empresario Lázaro báez acusado
de sido beneficiado con 51 obras que
eran financiadas con los fondos públicos
también fue acusado el exministro de
planificación Federal Julio debido Qué
impacto tiene Entonces esta decisión en
la política Argentina qué precedentes
sienta esto para la historia política
Argentina reciente como lo recibe la
sociedad Argentina porque aclaremos que
la sociedad Argentina está fuertemente
dividida polarizada en términos
políticos qué camino entonces comienza a
sembrar estos de Cara a esas
presidenciales del 2023 pues todas estas
preguntas las vamos a analizar aquí en
el debate de France 24 y para conversar
sobre este tema hemos invitado a Julio
rafo él es abogado exdiputado nacional y
legislador es también profesor de
filosofía del derecho y aquí en el
estudio de France 24 nos acompaña
Rodolfo colalongo él es analista
político también docente e investigador
de la Universidad externado de Colombia
universidad que está ubicada en la
ciudad de Bogotá ustedes nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
hacen parte de esta conversación de este
debate todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
ya lo saben estamos en Twitter en
Facebook en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba el
debate_f24@s antilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 y ya para terminar no se
olviden que todos los contenidos también
están disponibles en diferentes
plataformas de podcast estamos en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Julio en Argentina para conocer El
Punto de partida de esta conversación
puntos para conocer las opiniones de los
invitados como punto de inicial del
debate Julio Bienvenido al programa allí
en la ciudad de Buenos Aires y Qué
significa para la política Argentina y
Qué impacto tiene esta sentencia dictada
el día de hoy en Argentina
bueno primero es un precedente muy
importante
que un tribunal porqueado que después de
un largo proceso catorce años de
Procedimientos con garantizando el
derecho de defensa de todos con una
multiplicidad de acusados no solo la
vicepresidenta de la nación Cristina
Fernández de kirchner sino mucho los
funcionarios que vinculados con la obra
pública están involucrados
a uno de ellos fueron condenados o
diferentes penas algún otro fue absuelto
y bueno las cosas de los tribunales son
así
es un precedente importante y Avanza en
un fenómeno de corrupción muy grave que
a mi juicio ha habido en los gobiernos
del kirchnerismo
el enriquecimiento comprobado de dos
secretarios privados con departamentos
en frente al central parque en Miami el
crecimiento del señor Lázaro báez de
Ulloa en fin una
de la familia keiner se enriqueció mucho
de los amigos políticos y a su vez
algunas de ellas de la hija era el
presidente la encontraron cuatro
millones de dólares en una caja de
seguridad no está claro todavía el
origen O sea hay hechos graves
enriquecimiento y ahí estos graves de
incumplimiento de la obra pública y el
que hacía la obra pública era un amigo
cercano del presidente kirchner sí que
fundó su empresa
en cuando Quién fue electo a presidente
dentro del momento es electo y asumir en
ese momento se le ocurrió tener empresas
de Obras Públicas
vamos a conocer ahora la opinión de
Rodolfo aquí en el estudio de France 24
Rodolfo Bienvenido al programa Muchas
gracias y también el mismo Punto de
partida Qué significa para para la
política Argentina esta sentencia
dictada hoy Yo creo que Esto va a ser un
impacto profundo para lo que es la
política
Argentina por dos motivos primero porque
creo que la ponen en la palestra
política otra vez desde mi punto de
vista no es una estrategia política
acorde para lo que el macrismo Busca
esto es poder
quitarla de la escena política para de
esta manera poder tener unas elecciones
con mayor probabilidad de ganar que son
el año que viene
y por otro lado también digamos el
ponerla en el centro de la de la disputa
política lo que hace también es tapar un
poco la administración que está llevando
al Alberto Fernández que la verdad no es
muy buena con las evidencias que hay una
inflación terrible por lo tanto ella se
pone detrás y lo que hace es un poco
unir a todo el movimiento del frente que
no solo es el peronismo sino también hay
otros partidos políticos y que todos ya
se manifestaron a favor de digamos en
contra de la condena por lo tanto Creo
que políticamente hablando por lo menos
no es una estrategia correcta lo que
están llevando a cabo y lo que hacen es
justamente revitalizarla a ella y al
frente de todos para que llegue a las
elecciones del año que viene por lo
menos Unidos Ok pues después pueden
pasar muchas cosas pero que van a llegar
Unidos van a llegar Unidos Rodolfo la
ronda la inversa continuó con usted aquí
en el estudio ya le doy la palabra Julio
en la ciudad de Buenos Aires y le quiero
preguntar Rodolfo por la figura Quién es
Cristina de kirchner Cristina Fernández
de kirchner en este momento en la
política Argentina sabemos el gran
capital político que ya ha aumentado Y
arrastrado a lo largo de todos estos
años desde que su esposo fue presidente
no en vano fue dos veces presidenta de
Argentina
quién es ella en este momento Qué
representa ella en este momento para la
política Argentina Bueno hoy la política
Argentina no se puede entender sin la
presencia de
Cristina o sea es es el eje
gravitacional a través del cual toda la
política Argentina gira toda completa
por lo tanto es por ese Insisto que es
el impacto de la decisión judicial es
profunda Más allá de lo jurídico a nivel
político social y económico también o
sea el nivel político mueve lo social y
lo económico en el país por lo tanto
ahora Estamos viendo ahí un porcentaje
por dar un número pero el 50% del del
país está contento con la decisión
judicial siente que se hizo justicia
pero el otro 50% cree que no se hizo
justicia cree que lo que hay acá es una
corrupción al inversa es una corporación
jurídica que está haciendo una
persecución política con la referente
política que es Cristina Fernández de
kirchner digo nos guste o no nos guste
pero es la figura central de la política
Argentina hoy en día
y sin lugar a dudas toda la política
gira alrededor de ella digo las
principales noticias son Gracias y por
ella son A favor o en contra de ella ya
vamos a hablar le dejo la pregunta sobre
la mesa para analizarla más adelante lo
que significa el impacto que tiene esto
para la sociedad Argentina como usted
dice completamente polarizada de un lado
o del otro que impactó siembra esto
entre los argentinos paso a preguntarle
a Julio en la ciudad de Buenos Aires que
sigue para este proceso para los que no
conocemos la la legislación Argentina
este proceso lo decía yo en el bloque de
noticias y en la introducción del
programa que esto es un proceso que se
puede alargar se puede extender incluso
varios años ella no tiene que ir a la
cárcel inmediatamente qué es lo que
sigue entonces en este proceso para
entenderlo ciertamente hay apelación
recurso de ante el tribunal de casación
pidiendo los fiscales van a pedir que le
aumente la pena y que la declara
inocente casa hacían resolver algo que
tenga que resolver y después de eso hay
recursos a la Corte Suprema de Justicia
para los casos que hubiera arbitrariedad
o algún error pero yo quisiera
reflexionar dos minutos o lo que decía
Rodolfo que comparto gran parte de la
importancia y el eje que tiene Fernández
de kirchner pero no comparto en que haya
habido una decisión Del malacrismo de
hacer esto y ponerlo ahora los procesos
jurídicos tienen una lógica propia es el
políticamente los denunciantes hace 14
años que se inició este proceso están
integran hoy el macrismo son parte de la
coalición cívica quienes impulsaron esto
pero una vez que se inicia un proceso
tiene una cierta autodeterminación y una
lógica propia no se puede agarrar el
teléfono decirle Bueno ahora no lo leben
a juicio párenla en las audiencias
tienen y llega Ahora yo lo veo lo que yo
entiendo lo que yo creo no por decisión
política de algún sector de ponerla en
este momento en esa escena Y esto es no
llega en este momento de este año porque
el la lógica jurídica del proceso
judicial lo hizo llegar a este momento
en estas condiciones no había forma ni
de apresurarlo ni de atrasarlo a mi
juicio
Julio veíamos algunas de las
declaraciones que daba la la
vicepresidenta Argentina después de
darse a conocer este esta sentencia por
parte de la fiscalía y después de parte
de la justicia Argentina y ella
calificaba esto como un proceso donde no
hubo garantías donde incluso habló de
mafias en la Argentina actual y
entendiendo ya este contexto político y
entendiendo a Cristina Fernández Como un
eje central de la política Argentina que
tantas garantías hubo acá para un
proceso correcto con independencia de
poderes y se le puede creer a la
justicia Argentina en el escenario en el
que están ahora bueno han intervenido un
juez
tres camaristas de la cámara de
apelaciones Después
de casación tres más y después la corte
o sea son muchos los que han intervenido
y han ido legalizando son todos
corruptos son todos yo creo que que no
es así y hay una prueba
en la Argentina Es parte y ha sido
beneficiada con gran intensidad por la
el tribunal de o la Corte Interamericana
de Derechos Humanos de la oea que nos
ayudó tanto en la época de la dictadura
denunciando las arbitrariedades Cuando
alguien se ve perseguido a car
arbitrariamente tiene un recurso a la
corte de la oea para decirle mire me
están persiguiendo ilícitamente y
regularmente y la corte interviene no
han ido a tocar el timbre a pedir el
amparo de la Corte Interamericana por
qué
porque yo creo que si la corte en
examina este proceso nos va a encontrar
ninguna irregularidad Entonces es fácil
decirlo pero yo creo que ese es el
recurso cuando uno no se puede defender
con los hechos decir No no es verdad no
hice esto se defiende descalificando el
sistema no el sistema es injusto el
sistema persecutorio el sistema está mal
yo creo que no es así Acá hay colegio
Público de abogados Yo soy participo de
de como abogado de la matrícula hay hay
instituciones está el colegio el consejo
de la magistratura que durante mucho
tiempo tu hegemonía el partido de la de
la vicepresidenta es más estos jueces
que ella descalifica Fueron nombrados
por la vicepresidenta jueces y fueron
nombrados por un procedimiento de
Selección del Consejo de la magistratura
con hegemonía del partido de la
presidenta Entonces no sé cómo lo puede
calificar si no sentirse en
contradicción claro
me parece totalmente absurdo Esa
descalificación es la defensa que tiene
el que no se puede defender con los
hechos claro y aquí en el estudio France
24 Rodolfo está percepción de la
justicia Argentina es creíble a
independencia de poderes en el contexto
actual y retomando lo que usted dice que
ella se aleja central de la política y
bueno el kirchnerismo ha estado
dominando la política Argentina a lo
largo de la de los últimos años excepto
ese ese bache de cuatro años del
macrismo
mirar ahora yo no puedo hablar de la
justicia como tal Y cómo fue el proceso
judicial porque no soy un abogado
primero segundo no conozco el proceso en
sí pero si hay una percepción de que no
digamos que hay ciertas dudas al menos
se siembran y se plantean ciertas dudas
en relación con lo que fue este juicio
con la sentencia y con lo que se
denomina que una persecución política yo
la verdad te digo No creo que en
Argentina existe un poder judicial
independiente pero no es de ahora es de
hace muchísimo tiempo creo que las
últimas filtraciones que se hicieron
sobre los diferentes chats entre
hablando entre jueces camaristas y demás
te demuestra Cómo funcionan
independientemente que es una
conversación privada y demás Pero
privadamente hablaban como ellos
organizaban decían voy a pedir a quién
voy a hablar para allá entonces
realmente esto siempre a dudas ahora y
digo insisto no creo que tampoco existan
poderes independientes en otros estados
y lo digo en serio no No es un chiste
esto creo que hay un vínculo siempre
entre el poder político y el poder
judicial por eso estoy en contra de lo
que yo llamo la judicialización de la
política y esto está esa parte de los
hechos de corrupción una cosa es ser
corrupto y otra cosa es judicializar la
política Ok entonces si los hechos de
corrupción existen y demás sí existieron
y existen en todos los niveles a nivel
político y existen a nivel global Okay y
se persiguen Se buscan algunos se van a
condenar otros pero también existe algo
que se llama la judicialización de la
política y esto tiene que ver con que
Hay ciertos candidatos donde se los
Busca judicializarlos para sacarlos de
la escena política porque políticamente
representan mucho Entonces desde mi
punto de vista yo creo que esto va a
terminar siendo un Lula 2 y esto
hablábamos un poco antes entonces por
eso digo que estratégicamente Hablando
políticamente Hablando esto no va a
funcionar Por qué razón porque va a
revitalizar un escenario político que
estaba en una situación muy compleja le
va a dar aire nuevamente y le va a
permitir llegar con mucha más fuerza
para las elecciones que son Ahora son en
octubre del año que viene Ok y además
ganaron en las elecciones pasadas con
más del 50% Entonces yo lo analizo desde
lo político por eso Insisto que para mí
políticamente hablando y es un error
Okay ahora jurídicamente hablando
insisto no lo sé así que para eso vamos
a dejar que el abogado claro para que él
hable diga jurídicamente con nosotros y
por eso él daba su punto de vista sobre
este el punto de vista legal y de cómo
va se va a desarrollar este este caso
dentro de la justicia Argentina le hago
una pregunta a los dos había temor o hay
temor en diferentes ese esferas
políticas argentinas de que Cristina
volviera a la presidencia y por eso
estamos viendo este escenario ese
intento de asesinato ella tiene el
capital para regresar a la presidencia
usted Julio
el que ella tiene un importantísimo
coincido con Rodolfo capital político
que oscila entre un piso del 25 28 30
33% que es muchísimo tiene un nivel de
rechazo del 45 al 50% y hay un por
ciento de indeciso que después decidir
Así que él tiene un capital político
obviamente muy importante pero hay un
detalle que a mí me duele mucho y que no
yo una reflexión se lo que decía Rodolfo
no está dividido entre un 50 que dice
que es inocente y un 50 que dice
culpable muchos de los que lo defienden
y lo digo con mucha tristeza compañeros
míos de militancia política del
peronismo en la década del 70 me dicen
Julio robó no importa Yo la quiero igual
aunque sea ladrona y la defiendo porque
sus políticas más importantes que que
los delitos penales entonces muchos de
los que la defienden la defienden
sosteniendo que no les impone porque es
inocente porque no No importa que sea
ladrona y lo dicen en estos términos
hablando entre compañeros Y eso para mí
me parece una cosa espantosa y que puede
temblar hacer como bien dijo Rodolfo un
Lula dos o puede terminar siendo un
color de Melo dos que también fue un
presidente brasileño que también fue
acusado gravemente de hecho de intelecto
Y también fue preso y bueno podrá ser
una de las dos cosas el destino no no lo
puedo adivinar No ya veremos Cómo se
desarrolla todo este caso Julio continuó
con usted usted habla de estas
divisiones que hay entre incluso entre
peronistas sobre la percepción de
Cristina Fernández cómo está entonces al
interior del kirchnerismo el presidente
Fernández cerrará filas en torno a ella
para protegerla el kirchnerismo cerrará
filas en torno a ella o hay divisiones
internas que también sienten que ya es
momento de relevar un poco las caras y
que es momento de mover otras caras
políticas de Cara a esos a esos comicios
presidenciales
políticos muy de moda en otras décadas
tenían que en todos los fenómenos
sociales anida la contradicción
uno de ellos era más tú y yo no soy
magoísta pero
veo contradicciones en todos los
fenómenos sociales en mi familia hay
contradicciones y bueno Y en todo en el
kirchnerismo también las hay Lo
importante es y las contradicciones se
puede sintetizar para encontrar un rumbo
común o son tan antitéticas que rompen
el espacio en la cual se presenta Yo
creo que por ahora se pueden sintetizar
en el kirchnerismo porque con esa base
que tiene de 30% electorado hay muchos
dirigentes que es en privado lo dice que
no la quieren que no le gusta que saben
que perturba pero tienen que ir atrás de
ella porque tiene el 30% los votos y
ellos necesitan en sus municipios en sus
provincias esos votos Y entonces por
ahora yo no veo que vas a ver en el
kirchnerismo una fractura pero el
kinarismo es una parte del peronismo una
parte de hoy hegemónica tiene la
hegemonía del peronismo pero los
gobernadores hay muchos gobernadores
como este arete como de la provincia de
Córdoba que son peronistas pero no son
kiristas ahí se puede plantear una
fractura y le pasó aquí a la pregunta a
Rodolfo en el estudio entonces
entendiendo que no hay muchas fracturas
al interior del cristianismo esto se
puede tomar como se acabó esa luna de
miel del kirchnerismo y los argentinos
empieza una década o un periodo de
descenso de esa popularidad y ese
Encanto que hubo que los llevó a
gobernar durante tanto tiempo puede
tomarse como eso un cierre de un
capítulo
en parte coincido con el análisis que
está haciendo mi colega Yo creo que el
ingenierismo esto lo va a tomar como un
elemento ya dije recién de aire de
insufrible un poco de aire para que
puedan revivir y se van a reagrupar en
torno a esto es una de las
características que el peronismo tiene
el peronismo cuando hay una crisis se
cierre internamente se fortalece y sigue
y por otro lado Lo que sí es cierto es
que el killerismo hace parte de una
coalición de gobierno que es el frente
de todos y yo también creo que en el
frente de todos es muy posible que
figure una digamos una lógica similar
Esto va a lograr cerrar filas alrededor
de el killerismo y lo que va a hacer es
reposicionarlos para las elecciones que
vienen yo no creo que este tipo de
crisis lo que haga es fracturar sino que
es al revés este tipo de crisis unen por
esa razón insisto en que políticamente
hablando no es estratégico claro
judicializar la política de esta manera
porque en realidad es el tiro te sale al
revés lo que se busca es anularla
políticamente y lo que en el al fin al
cabo sucede es revitalizar la
políticamente
la estás martirizando ella logra tiene
un canal en YouTube donde después de que
los tres jueces dieron una sentencia ya
da su propia sentencia sobre lo lo que
sucedió y presenta y pantallas y no sé
qué
y además todo el contexto político que
rodea al kirchnerismo y al frente de
todos ya habían cerrado filas y todos
dijeron O casi todos dijeron No señores
esto no no funciona así esta
judicialización que se está haciendo No
es correcta No vamos por buen camino
Entonces desde mi punto de vista esto
revitaliza ahora significa que van a
ganar las elecciones que viene No lo sé
sin embargo si les dan si le está dando
un porcentaje le está dando un piso y
una fuerza para tener una lucha Y además
quitar de lado lo que se viene atrás
usted habla que se revitaliza Entonces
el kirchnerismo el peronismo tiene la
costumbre de cerrarse y revitalizarse de
Cara a a estos conflictos que se
presentan pero que hay de la sociedad
Argentina una sociedad que ya está
polarizada que ya está dividida Esto
entonces qué hace profundizas tanto le
ha costado a los argentinos volver a
cerrar Sin lugar a dudas yo creo que
Esto va a ser así no sé si yo dije 50 50
con una forma de decir No sé si ese es
el porcentaje Pero hay una división
Clara uno lo ve Ok y la división Clara
lo único que va a hacer es favorecer los
argumentos depende del lado entonces
insisto aquellos que consideran que
Cristina es corrupta dijeron Ya está la
justicia lo dijo Es corrupta y aquellos
que consideran que no lo es te van a
decir No no es y te van a agarrar la
sentencia te la van a analizar y te van
a decir mira todas las inconsistencias
jurídicas que hay para después
argumentar que existe una corporación
jurídica lo único que hace es perseguir
a los líderes populares que quieren
transformar al país por lo tanto esto no
va a dar una solución si el otro punto
políticamente hablando era cerrar una
grieta Esto está haciendo exactamente el
efecto contrario la está profundizando
cada vez más por eso es que ninguna de
las dos son estrategias políticas que
funcionen para un objetivo si vos me
decís Cuál es el objetivo cerrar la
grieta no funciona posicionarme yo
nosotros como movimiento para tampoco
funciona Entonces mi duda política está
ahí están decir tenemos que repensar
realmente las estrategias políticas y la
judicialización política no funciona Eso
es lo que quiero decir paso a
preguntarle a Julio en la ciudad de
Buenos Aires me llama la atención un
comentario que usted hizo Julio sobre la
relación que tiene con sus amigos y
personas cercanas cuando hablan de
política y me llama la atención esa
condescendencia que hay por parte de
algunos argentinos frente al
kirchnerismo les y cierran filas en
torno a ellos pese a saber y tener muy
claros algunos de los errores que han
cometido a lo largo de este de este
gobierno no solamente de Cristina sino
también de de Néstor kirchner en su
momento por qué Por qué los los
argentinos se cierran en torno a ellos
bueno Es una muy buena pregunta y
dolorosa pregunta Hay alguno de ellos
que dicen vea Julio hay que financiar la
política hay en la Argentina una buena
ley de enfrentamiento de la política no
No la hay Y entonces tienen que robar
para poder hacer política y financiar la
política Bueno yo esto lo condeno y
quiero señalar que en realidad esta
causa no es un hecho de judicialización
de la política Cristina tiene como nueve
causas hay dos de ellas que claramente
lo son la del memorando un cólera en
Irán en que fue acusada de encubrimiento
del atentado lamia y otra del dólar
futuro que estableció un criterio bueno
esas causas Sí pero esta es una causa de
investigación un delito de corrupción
como la causa de espirone El
vicepresidente de Kennedy de Kennedy
perdón de Nixon que los que lo
investigaron por por fraude fiscal no
judía los norteamericanos no
judicializaron la política cuando lo
acusaron aspiro a Ángel de corrupto es
que era corrupto y una investigación de
un delito O sea no era un hecho político
llevado a la justicia era un hecho de
delito que es un hecho de delito común
esta causa no es una judicialización de
la política es la investigación de un
delito hay otras que lo son hay dos o
tres que las son pero esta no
Julio continúo con usted para
preguntarle Entonces esto Cómo va
llenando el terreno político de Cara a
esas elecciones del 2023 creo que ya
esto nos va diciendo un poco que va a
estar bastante reñido va a estar la lupa
de los medios de comunicación encima de
Argentina a lo largo del año entrante
para ver cómo se va a encarrilar esas
elecciones presidenciales de octubre
encuestas lo dan al oficialismo actual
como perdedor los propios dirigentes de
los oficialismo actual salvo el
presidente pero no ha dicho la
vicepresidenta las próximas elecciones
la perdemos tenemos que pararnos para el
27 y la objetivo táctico estratégico
para enfrentar esta situación es ganar
en la provincia de Buenos Aires que se
puede ganar ahí no hay segunda vuelta se
gana por un voto entonces uno tiene el
33% 34 gana si nosotros no van Unidos en
cambio la presidencial según
el valor tal se juntan y las encuestas
hoy
y que el oficialismo actual pierde
largamente por el alto nivel de rechazo
que tiene tienes el núcleo duro de
treinta y tres treinta y cinco treinta y
siete no más y según encuestas
diferentes empresas unas que trabajan
para el oficialismo otras para la
oposición Pero todas coinciden En eso yo
creo que es un dato hoy sacando la foto
hoy ven una foto hoy pierde esto es la
política es una película hay que ver la
dinámica que termina pasando si ya se
victimiza que reacciones hay en fin
pueden pasar muchas cosas pero hoy las
encuestas lo dan al oficialismo de
perdedor y que análisis hace usted a
Rodolfo canela France 24 Cómo ve
entonces usted esta película de lo que
comienza a partir de hoy para esas
elecciones presidenciales difíciles pero
mira te voy a decir una cosa que había
dicho Julio recién en relación porque
tiene ese fuerte apoyo ahí hay una frase
que no es mía que dice que las
evidencias tienen cada vez menos peso en
la formación de los sentidos y esto
quiere decir de que yo no necesito
evidencias a favor
para inclinarme por un líder sino lo que
yo necesito es tener ese feeling y ese
contacto que tengo y es lo que hoy se
está logrando y se está haciendo con la
mayoría de los líderes populares en la
región y en el resto del mundo que
tienen esa capacidad independientemente
si es cierto o no No me importa yo lo
voy a votar igual o yo estoy Atrás de
esa filas también
en este sentido y es verdad las
encuestas hoy dicen de que ellos pierden
Es lógico tienen un gobierno que no da
flote que no da con la tecla en lo
económico están cada vez peor sin
embargo también es cierto de que es un
proceso largo hasta octubre las cosas
pueden cambiar y además las encuestas
nos demuestran que no siempre tienen la
capacidad para acertar con los
resultados en el 90% de los casos le
erran Y erran por muchas cifras desde mi
punto de vista y siguiendo este análisis
que las evidencias tienen cada vez menos
peso en la formación de los sentidos Yo
realmente creo que el gran peligro que
representa Cristina en la política es su
capacidad para atraer Ok entonces en
este punto de vista Yo creo que tiene
más que un plazo suficiente para
establecer una estrategia políticamente
hablando de Cara a las elecciones que
son el año que viene por ahora ella dijo
que no se iba a presentar en ningún
cargo de más pero desde mi punto de
vista se está victimizando un poco está
poniendo en situación a ver dentro del
movimiento que hacemos que van a hacer
ustedes sin mí para de esta manera
concretar esa cuestión que tienen Y a
partir de ahí pensar en una estrategia
para el poco calentando sus bases
exactamente generándole ese malestar esa
necesidad es una estrategia que no
solamente hemos visto en Argentina lo
hemos visto en otros países de muchos
otros lugares también es bastante común
y además funciona
logra concretar Esa esa iniciativa Qué
hay de la violencia política lo que
hemos visto en Argentina los últimos
meses ese ese intento de asesinato de
Cristina también
eso cómo va a repercutir en estas
elecciones en el 2023 bueno Esa fue otra
otra cosa no el hecho de que hayan
intentado que bueno después hay unas
dudas que si fueron que no fueron que
ahora están presos bueno en fin Tampoco
voy a entrar en la discusión lo cierto
porque no lo sabemos claro nunca sabes
si realmente o fue armado no fue armado
que se mostró en fin pero no es el punto
acá pero el punto es que insisto fueron
dos elementos que políticamente si la
benefician a ella Entonces eso por un
lado y por otro lado si demuestra que la
violencia política e institucional en
Argentina estamos cada vez peor o sea
nosotros Hace mucho tiempo que estamos
acá sabemos que en Colombia esas cosas
son comunes que acá el tema de la
seguridad sí se toma muy en serio que
hay una seguridad presidencial de los
ministerios y demás que es una Cosa
increíble pero en Argentina eso no
existe no existía porque no era
necesario que una vicepresidenta pudiera
tener un esquema de seguridad como tiene
un vicepresidente acá sin embargo era
porque las condiciones de la
institucionalidad política permitían que
uno y los funcionarios públicos pudieran
estar con un Custodio con dos que
simplemente le diga a la gente por favor
cuidado cuidado y que esta persona pueda
circular libremente por los espacios esa
situación cambió Entonces esto nos está
hablando de que el deterioro de la
violencia política a nivel social ya se
trasladó a nivel político y a nivel
institucional ya estamos hablando de con
dos custodios a un vicepresidente no
hace falta tenemos que poner un esquema
más robusto porque evidentemente puede
pasarle esto no había pasado desde mil
creo que él lo sabe mejor que yo Julio
pero fue en el siglo 19 la última vez
que Habían intentado matar a un
presidente en la República argentina se
imaginate es una cosa es una figura
exactamente de la escena política de ese
país Julio lo decíamos ella representa
las bases del kirchnerismo en la
actualidad es la vicepresidenta
Argentina y también es dos veces
presidenta de este país suramericano
esto como es una vicepresidenta en
funciones Cómo afecta esto al gobierno
que está de turno en este momento Cómo
afecta esto al presidente Fernández y a
su administración Porque también se ha
hablado mucho que ella es realmente el
poder en las sombras de esta
administración
bueno primer lugar hay fuertes
contradicciones entre el presidente
Fernández y ella ella lo ha criticado
públicamente y muchos de sus seguidores
lo han agraviado públicamente y con el
beneplácito ostensible de ella o sea que
no No todos son rosas en esta historia
eh jurídicamente No lo afectan nada
porque no hay condena firme el rige
jurídicamente la presunción de inocencia
y hay que aceptarla y es una garantía
que tenemos todos los y bueno es así y
ahora políticamente me parece que
empuja agudizar los contradicciones una
de las contradicciones es que el
presidente Fernández ha dicho muchas
veces insiste en que quiere ser
candidato en el 23 y el kirchnerismo lo
han dicho por diferentes modos y más
directos o indirectos no quieren que se
hagan que no corresponde su candidatura
y esto entonces viene a traer en el
escenario de la decisión Quién va a ser
candidato La una mochila
a la vicepresidenta y más ahora que dijo
que no va a ser pero coincido que es un
acting de que no va a ser para para
convocar y victimizarse y posicionarse y
salir fortalecida en esto pero no quería
decir
ese gran presidente que político
brasileño fue tan credone ves es una
frase extraordinaria en política no
importan los hechos sino la versión
y con respecto al atentado de muerte que
yo no sé qué grado hay porque no he
visto el expediente no lo puedo decir lo
que sí sé que las encuestas que ha
circulado dicen que el sesenta por
ciento los argentinos creen que fue
armado y que el juego fue un atentado
verdadero bueno no yo no lo sé no puedo
afirmarlo uno lo otro pero sí sé que es
un dato de la realidad claro la mayoría
de los argentinos desconfían de la
veracidad de ese atentado hemos hablado
a lo largo de este programa del lado
oficialista de lo que representa este
hecho para la política Argentina Pero
entonces quiero darle la vuelta a de
todo esto para este bloque final del
programa y es como la oposición
Argentina puede capitalizar esto de
caras a selecciones y que oportunidad
pueden tener ellos porque obviamente
esto es política esto es un juego y todo
debe ser aprovechado para ganar el voto
que sea necesario comienzo por Julio
preguntándole cómo capitaliza Esto
entonces la oposición la oposición
también tiene profunda contradicciones
internas y ya se vislumbran y se han
hecho peleas por la candidatura entonces
hay una de dos o llega unida a pesar de
esa contradicciones Y entonces va
capitalizar fuertemente todo la el
imagen negativa que tienen los líderes o
referentes del oficialismo o llega
dividida Y si llega dividida y se abre
una gran incógnita que es lo que creo
que apuesta el presidente Fernández
cuando insiste su candidatura porque
piensa nosotros tenemos un piso del 28
el 30 33 pero los otros divididos cada
uno tiene menos no llegan Entonces vamos
a ganar bueno y la gran incógnita es va
a superar armónicamente
la oposición su contradicciones o no en
las candidaturas no lo puedo afirmar
pero está planteado en el escenario
dramáticamente en este momento Claro que
sí en este lado aquí en el estudio
Rodolfo yo creo que sí se van a centrar
mucho en la decisión judicial en la
condena o sea ese va a ser la principal
estrategia política que debería usar el
el macrismo con sus todas sus vertientes
ese explotar la imagen negativa producto
de esto decir miren ya no es nuestra
imaginación que es corrupta lo es está
confirmado Ok tiene una condena es
verdad le quedan dos dos instancias más
bueno una y después ir a la corte pero
por lo menos políticamente lo que
deberían hacer es utilizar esta imagen
que ya tiene para poder decir miren si
ustedes quieren a una candidata a su
candidata va a ser corrupta
judicialmente corrupta entonces empezar
a explotar esa imagen que ya la vienen
haciendo hace rato pero no habían
logrado que una decisión judicial pueda
favorecerlos en este caso políticamente
Aunque por otro lado para mí es un error
pero si yo fuera
de la oposición yo les diría tenemos que
explotar políticamente la decisión
judicial claro directamente mostrarlo en
el fender y decir Miren esta candidata
puede ser que tenga una cantidad de
votos y demás pero es corrupta Y si
ustedes quieren votar un corrupto pues
entonces nos dedicamos a otra cosa pero
nosotros estamos totalmente alejados de
esa imagen Y nosotros se lo veníamos
diciendo hace muchísimos años de que
ella era corrupta entonces creo que
políticamente lo que deberían hacer es
concentrarse nuevamente cerrar filas
atrás de eso y comenzar a explotar cada
vez más exactamente firme Sólido y
permitir que la causa avance o sea
seguir incentivando a través de los
medios y demás que aparte tienen un gran
apoyo de los principales medios
sacar esas noticias poder cerrarlo ahí
poder decir que la causa avance
presionar al poder judicial para que
pueda tener Digamos si se apela que sea
en el menor tiempo posible
y explotarlo
políticamente o sea comunicacionalmente
formando sentidos Como dijo Julio recién
es necesario que formen sentidos como
esta cosa el 60% de los argentinos según
esta encuesta cree que el atentado no
fue un atentado sino informando eso
formar sentido formar sentidos
políticamente aunque uno esté en contra
aunque uno esté en contra pero es formar
sentidos políticamente es darle un
sentido a una situación que sucedió y
canalizarla para que vos obtengas un
crédito político de acá las próximas
elecciones y repito no es que estemos
acá enseñando la conspiración perfecta
es que es parte del juego político no
obvio que cualquiera de los partidos no
solamente en Argentina en cualquier país
del mundo estarían pensando cómo
aprovechar la situación para ganar más
votos y los otros Cómo aprovechar la
situación para mostrar y despertar
sentimientos en los en los en los
votantes me queda un minuto para
finalizar el programa Julio usted ya fue
muy claro diciéndome que no puede ver el
futuro que no sabe qué va a pasar en
esta situación pero que él espera
Argentina con situación esto en qué va a
terminar por lo menos las próximas
semanas rápidamente y muy puntual por
favor tenemos un drama tremendo con la
situación económica y social tenemos un
país con 50% de pobreza el treinta no sé
cuánto de indigencia El 38 de
desocupación en un país socialmente en
la situación dramática lo político se
monta sobre esto y esto qué estructura
situación social pues económica influye
sobre los políticos Claro que gane salga
lo que salga en el año 2023
un camino duro para resolverle el
problema a los argentinos o intentar
mitigarlo
Rodolfo rápidamente su conclusión para
el cierre Sí yo creo que va a ser un
camino difícil lo que le espera en las
próximas semanas y el próximo cierre de
año y próximo año va a ser un camino
complicado difícil para Alberto
Fernández y un panorama muy complicado
para quien gane las próximas elecciones
en Argentina La verdad la tiene muy
difícil Rodolfo Julio Muchísimas gracias
gracias por este análisis para la
audiencia de France 24 es todo por el
momento En nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos su sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Andrés
doncel y la producción de invitados a
cargo de Lina Guzmán Gracias sigan con
Franz 24
[Música]